checking if the sound's working
am I turned on can you hear me at the
back yes good all right just give it
another moment for people to sit down
all right
okay well I know people are still coming
in that's absolutely fine but we will
get started now so um good morning
everyone and welcome to the Friday of
your conference well done for making it
out of your warm beds and getting over
here I want to reassure you that we are
the cool ones not the ones that are
still in their beds
um gold stars to us we're we're great
okay
um so this talk uh is going to be about
the web and how the web got to where it
is today my name's Steve and I work at
Microsoft I'm on the.net team and I
think I've spent my entire professional
career up until this point doing stuff
related to the web
um and I bet the web is a central part
of many of your careers as well can you
give me a hands up if you do stuff
related to web technology yeah I mean
it's like almost everyone isn't it
apologies to the small number of people
who feel left out now
um but you know I'm sure the web is
important in your life as well and it's
a good area to work in because it's
always changing there's always something
new to to learn we're always making it
more and more complicated and you might
wonder well why is that why does it
constantly change why is it always
getting more and more complicated is
this a good idea who's making these
decisions and are they making terrible
mistakes well that's what we're going to
look at in this talk today we're going
to go through some of the history of how
the web got to where it is today and
think about where it might go next now
of course like any history it's a
subjective story it's just one person's
opinion it's not the objective truth so
um is a good chance that I won't cover
everything it's entirely possible that
I'll miss out whatever you personally
care about most so if I do miss out
something you care about please
understand that is a hundred percent
deliberate I've meticulously researched
every person in this room so that I
could systematically exclude everything
that you most care about okay you're
welcome all right so let's get into this
shall we where would we start with the
story of the web I think the obvious
place to start is within invention of
the web and our good friend sir Tim
berners-lee and I know most of you will
know about him you'll have heard about
him and you will know that he invented
the web while he was working at CERN in
Switzerland but do you know why like
what was he actually trying to achieve
what did he think that he was doing at
the time that he invented this and how
did it go well The Story Goes a bit like
this so CERN is a very complicated place
to work they've got some pretty
sophisticated projects going on like
literally building particle accelerators
so a lot to keep track of and
berners-lee kept track of his work in an
electronic notebook system that he
programmed himself it was some software
called inquire and it was a place that
he could type in his notes and he had
one pretty cool feature in there which
is that he could link from one note to
another so you might be able to see
where this is going right it's an early
hypertext system that he'd created and
he liked it a lot he thought he was
brilliant and that everyone at CERN
should be using this he wanted to
standardize on it but he didn't just
want everyone to use it independently he
wanted it to be all networked together
so that everyone's notebooks could link
to everyone else's notebooks and they
could all see and edit each other's
content so he made this proposal
information management and he published
it in CERN and you can read it today
it's a bit hard to make sense of a lot
of it because a lot of it is quite
specific to CERN but there are some
parts in here that you would recognize
and understand for example this in this
diagram he shows the idea of having a
client browser which is a multi-platform
software and it can connect to hypertext
servers and those servers can link to
other hypertext servers that's very
recognizable he also interestingly had
this idea that the hypertext wouldn't
just be written by hand but could be
generated on the fly from database
content so he was coming up with this
idea of server-side rendering here in
the very first proposal and if you're
wondering why he cared about doing that
well this was his hack to get people to
actually use it he knew if he just
published this proposal on its own
people around him would go oh that's a
nice proposal well done Tim and then
they just completely ignore it have you
ever had that experience happen to you
in your workplace yeah pretty common now
he knew that would happen so his hack
was to take some information that people
needed the CERN phone book and make it
available in his system so they would
have to use it okay but he didn't just
write this proposal he also wrote some
software
he wrote the first web server and the
first web browser to demonstrate how it
could work and I've got the code for
both of those right here so we can have
a look and see where this all started
all right so this is bernersley's
original web server it's a C file it's
uh how big is that it's 730 something
lines of code written in uh October 1990
and the code quality in here
I mean it's clearly a prototype right
we've all done some pretty dubious
things in our prototypes and that's fine
it's just to explore the ideas but the
important thing about this is that it
really works okay and we can still
compile it and run it today I had to
make about I think maybe three small
tweaks to the code and then it actually
compiled with a modern GCC compiler so
this compiles TCP server.c to produce a
binary called HTTP D HTTP Daemon and you
can see it's very tiny under 22
kilobytes and I can run it now directly
on my machine there we go and you can
see it says that it's listening on Port
2784 that's a bit weird isn't it why is
it 2784 shouldn't it before 80 well
we'll talk about that in a minute
um now I can't connect to this from a
normal web browser or a modern web
browser anyway because this only speaks
a very ancient dialect of HTTP which
modern browsers will not talk at all so
the only way we can connect to this
really now is to do so by hand I'm going
to use telnet so if you know much about
the HTTP protocol you might imagine that
you could do something like this get and
then slash to get the home page but that
doesn't work okay I'm not entirely sure
why it just doesn't but if you reverse
engineer the the source code a little
bit what you'll find is what you can do
is you can type in the name of a file
that is on disk and it will serve that
file to you so the original web server
is a static file server which is
something we still do today so that's
pretty understandable but it's not just
a static file server it's also got a
bunch of features that might be a little
harder for us to understand like it's
got this built-in find feature where it
can search a set of disks whatever that
means in this case so I'm not entirely
sure what that's doing but you know it's
exploring some ideas
and it's also where berners-lee
introduces a beautiful tradition that
continues to this day for all web
servers which is to have terrible
security vulnerabilities okay and it
gives us a good example of how to do it
right here on line 286 you can see here
that it's calling out to the Shell this
is a system command it's like running a
you know A bash executable or whatever
and what is that system command well
it's just whatever has been entered by
the user so you can just send a request
and it'll just run arbitrary stuff on
the server which is quite nice you know
very generous of whoever runs the server
there and in terms of this port number
it started off as 2784 but a little
while later in version three they
changed it to Port 80. that was
allocated by someone else about 31 years
ago
um and that's when the the team working
on this really felt that they'd made it
and this old number by the way
apparently was the last four digits of
bernersley's parents phone number so
yeah don't know why you chose that but
there you go all right so that's the
first web server he also created his
original idea of a web browser I'm going
to show you that it's a bit more
sophisticated actually so let's have a
look at that in here this is the next
step operating system anyone ever use
Next Step here wow two or three people
have I did not expect that all right so
next step uh next was a computer company
run by Apple uh no run by Steve Jobs who
was kicked out of apple he went off to
find this new computer company NeXT and
they eventually went back to Apple later
but while
um next was creating this they did a lot
of great innovation in the operating
system world and many of the features of
next you can still see today in Mac OS
for example it's got the spinny beach
ball thing whenever it's busy it's also
got this multi-column file browser which
you would recognize from Mac OS today
and inside here I've got the source code
for this web browser and again it can be
compiled and it can be run today so
let's do that so I've got this installed
and when that comes up you'll see it's a
little bit different to what we think of
as a web browser today
first difference is every page you go to
comes up in its own separate window that
just kind of floats around independently
so a different idea of you know
different from the multi-tab setup that
we have today it's got some stuff that
you might think that you understand like
this back next previous and so on I'm
afraid you're mistaken those do not mean
what you think they mean they've changed
their meanings over time at this time it
meant something like go backwards and
forwards through all the links in this
page which is a bit harder to understand
it's also got some stuff that you
perhaps wouldn't have expected like can
you see here that it's got a check
spelling option so why would you want to
check the spelling of a web page that
you've gone to that seems a bit strange
doesn't it well actually there's a great
reason for it which is that this is not
just for viewing web pages you can edit
any web page you go to because remember
this is meant to be a sort of shared
notebook thing so of course you can just
go and edit you want to make sure you
don't make any spelling mistakes and
it's got other cool surprising things
like it's got this style picker I can
choose different styles even got this
whole thing where you can design the
styles that are in your document and
it's got all these built-in Diagnostics
as well so it's kind of like early
browser Dev tools showing up there so at
the same time this is really an alien
kind of browser to us but it's also got
a load of ideas that we still recognize
now
all right so let's get out of there and
move back into the
slides all right so there was a little
bit of a critical problem with this
whole thing with this prototype so
bonusly had made this browser that works
on NeXT computers but no one else apart
from Tim actually had a next computer
inside CERN so you know it's kind of
hard to see how this was going to catch
on but fortunately someone came along to
save the day Nikola pelo was an intern
at CERN at the time and she could see
what was going on and the fact that you
know this had potential but clearly not
going to work if no one else can run the
browser thankfully she invented a way of
rendering that hypertext to a plain text
format that would run inside the
terminal computers that people actually
did have at the time a very good job
that that happened if it didn't I don't
think we would be talking about the web
today but the fact that it did meant
that this was able to catch on inside
CERN and in fact they then made it
available to the public through Usenet
and it caught on very quickly a lot of
people got very enthusiastic and started
creating their own browsers and we
started to see a development towards
browse as we know today one of the most
important and Innovative ones was this
one called Viola or Viola I don't know
how to pronounce it by Payway and it has
some of the UI patterns that we
recognize now like it's got the address
bar at the top and the you know the back
and forward stuff that we know about it
also innovated in some really impressive
technical ways for one thing Pei Wei
came up with the idea of having this
style sheet language inside the browser
now it's not CSS obviously that hadn't
been invented yet but you can kind of
see where we're going here like you can
pretty much write that code yourself
today you could understand it just from
the syntax but even more impressively he
put in scripting
so the entire browser was written in the
scripting language and he allowed people
to embed the same scripts inside their
web pages to dynamically change the
content not JavaScript obviously but
again it's setting a direction for what
web pages would actually be but people
didn't really use this browser at scale
because it was limited to Unix systems
they didn't all have that the first
browser that was cross-platform and was
really used by a lot of people was this
one NCSA Mosaic and I'm going to show it
to you right now
okay so I'm going to show this inside
Windows 3.1 a little bit before my time
I'm pleased to say but I think we can
work out how to use it okay so here's
Mosaic and I'm going to start it up oh
no I'm not because we've got a terrible
problem what's this can't find windsock
well this version of Windows is so old
it does not even have built-in support
for TCP networking so to enable that you
have to run this bizarre third-party
thing called Trumpet winsock which is a
lovely name and once you've got that
running you can start up your browser
and it should actually work okay now I
can't connect this to the modern web or
I have actually tried I've got it
working on the internet but modern web
servers don't speak the version of HTTP
that this wants to use so the only way I
can show you it doing something is to
just open a local HTM file so here we go
this is the original Mosaic homepage
which would have come up when you first
install the browser and you can see it
pretty much resembles what a web page
should be it's got paragraphs it's got
unordered lists it's got links the links
are blue when I hover over it the cursor
turns into a little hand with the URL
appearing at the bottom so so many
things that we understand and recognize
and expect today all in here but the
biggest Innovation I think something you
might not have even noticed as we went
past it is this image up at the top so
this is an inline image which was a big
technical step forwards prior to this
browsers would only open images in
external windows but in this browser the
image can be in line in the page and
clearly that's a very critical part of
what web browsers need to be so how did
that come about you might wonder how was
the image tag standardized what was the
standardization process at that time
well there were no standards bodies back
then in 93 all they had was a mailing
list and one day a certain chap called
Mark Anderson who we'll hear more about
later he was working on this Mosaic
browser and he said I'd like to propose
a new tag and we're going to call it Ing
and it will have a required argument of
cirque and he gives an example of that
at the bottom and if you're a web
developer you'll recognize that syntax
and immediately there was a reply that
came back from Tony Johnson saying oh
yeah I've already invented that exact
same thing except mine is different and
also
do we really have to call it immenserk
can't we give it sensible names like
image and source and that's a pretty
good question I think we could probably
all agree why didn't we do that
unfortunately nobody addressed this
point whatsoever because the next thing
that happened was that berners-lee came
along to weigh in and he said no no this
is all completely wrong we can't do it
like that we're not going to have ing an
image should obviously be represented as
an a tag with Rel equals embed or
present because that's much more
intuitive developers are going to like
that
and they had a little bit of a debate
that went on for a few days a
berners-lee was really saying you know
the a tag would be much more appropriate
for this use case but he also made a
little bit of a tactical blunder because
he said oh don't in any case we can't
change HTML because it's going through a
standardization process right now so we
just can't change it we can't do a new
thing right now sorry and that gave
Andreessen the opportunity to just have
his own way because he came back then
and said oh Tim I absolutely agree with
you in all cases which is why I'm going
to completely ignore your position on
this subject and do what I want anyway
um because I can't wait for your
standardization process I'm doing real
world work here and then he went on to
say Yeah we're definitely going with
imgenserk because you know I wasn't
really asking your permission I was just
telling you this was all pointless okay
so that's how the standardization went
down at that time
um I don't know if bernersley felt
burned At All by that but coincidentally
the following year he founded the w3c an
organization that has a kind of moral
authority to tell browser makers what
they should do and what standards they
should follow and this was part of a
period of very rapid growth for the web
like by now there were literally
thousands of websites which you know is
absurdly small but it was growing at a
rate of about a factor of 10 every
single year between about 94 and 99 or
something like that so so many orders of
magnitude of growth during the rest of
that decade incredible growth and it's
when some of the big companies and big
brands that we know started to get in on
it so the first one to mention uh it
wasn't a big company originally actually
Netscape let's get was a startup and it
was our friend Mark Andreessen again so
he finished working on Mosaic and he
went to work with someone else and they
set up a startup and they were not
planning to make a browser at all they
were going to make a gaming Network for
the Nintendo 64 console that was their
plan but Nintendo was taking too long to
release this console and so they said
like oh what are we going to do we can't
wait anymore should we come up with
something else I don't know shall we
just like make another browser or
something like that so they did and
that's how Netscape came to be doing
what it was doing and that went on to
IPO the following year for a lot of
money and that started the.com Bubble
um it also attracted the attention of
some of the big players you might have
heard of a certain Microsoft who came
into the market the following year they
licensed the NCSA Mosaic source code
they wrapped it in some windowsey stuff
and they released that as Internet
Explorer one and that started the first
browser was between Netscape and ie as
you might know IE went on to win that
pretty conclusively it got I don't know
it was like 96 market share or something
by 2001 so in a sense that was a huge
success but it also caused some pretty
serious legal troubles for the company
but that's how that went along
um but let's stop talking about browsers
for a little bit let's talk now about
the people writing the code that was uh
implementing actual web applications so
how would you write a web application at
this time well you could just write HTML
by hand in notepad or something like
that or you could use something like
Perl scripts and CGI bin and other very
low-tech solutions to connect code to
your web server but then someone came
along Rasmus lured off saying wouldn't
it be better if we had a dedicated
language for generating web pages and he
released the personal home page tools to
help people do that now the syntax is
completely different these days but the
original syntax was this like HTML
comments that embedded code and it had
some cool and useful features like you
can see it can connect to a database
they're about halfway down it's doing a
SQL query which is powerful and useful
and yes of course it has a SQL injection
vulnerability I know we can see that it
had to right that was the way of things
that was the culture at the time you had
to have SQL injection vulnerabilities or
you were just not you know playing the
game in the way that you should do all
right so that was early PHP
um Rasmus was not completely confident
in what he was doing it seems when he
was asked a bit later he was like I'm
not really sure what I was doing here
but we have to acknowledge that this has
been one of the most successful web
Technologies there's ever been despite
all this you know much of the early web
was built with it Facebook used it at
scale very very successful technology
despite just how sort of you know
pragmatic the approach was to create and
get all right now that brings us into
the world of the front end we haven't
mentioned that yet I think we could say
96 was the year when front end was born
because that's when JavaScript was
invented and CSS and two of the big
consumer facing web page creation
Technologies I'm going to show you one
of those right now I'm going to show you
front page okay so let's imagine that
it's 96.97 you've just heard about
this.com bubble and you want to get
yourself very very rich okay so I'm
going to open up this uh
a copy of Windows XP okay no Windows 95
in fact uh we're web developers in about
96 we're probably going to be running
Windows 95 and we've just installed
Microsoft front page so let's see what
the experience of creating a web
application would be like back then
okay well I don't really know what I'm
doing so I'm going to create it from a
wizard or template okay what are we
going to do well the goal is to get rich
right so we're going to create a
corporate presence I think and we'll
call it I don't know we'll call it Steve
Club it sounds like a good name to me
all right so what's it going to do well
it's going to ask us a few questions
about this site that we want to create
right now like what do we want to have
on it I don't know more stuff oh yeah
let's have a mission statement because
very 90s and then it's going to ask us
more stuff and it just keeps going on
and on and on with so many questions and
eventually it lets us finish the wizard
and it's going to create this website
for us now Microsoft at the time they
knew that people didn't know how to
create web pages so one of the features
in here was this cool thing where it
teaches you what to do it gives you all
the steps needed to create your web page
and allows you to assign tasks and
things like that it also gives you this
nice graphical overview of your site and
all the links in it and you can double
click on a page and you can get into the
editor
right now in terms of the graphic design
here remember this is meant to be the
corporate website okay so I'm not
completely sure what was going on in the
minds of the people in Redmond at that
time
um but you know you could come in here
and you can start typing out your web
page content and stuff but the more
impressive thing was it's got some
really powerful features such as the
ability to add script and you can write
script in the new JavaScript that's just
been invented or vbscript and with the
simple click of a checkbox you can make
that script run on your server as well
so it's very very powerful dangerously
powerful and this was the classic ASP
phase of web development where people
could write VB and it would just run
some code on the server it gets us into
a little bit of trouble as well which
we'll mention in a minute but let's get
out of here no I don't need to save that
all right okay so what about JavaScript
and CSS well you might have heard a
story about how JavaScript was created
in 10 days well apparently it's true so
Brendan Ike he got hired to work at
Netscape when they were working towards
Netscape too and his boss was Mark
Andreessen who we've heard of okay and
Andreessen came to him and said hey
Brendan
um in about 10 days we're going to be
having an all hands meeting and we're
looking for some cool demos wondered if
you could do something like I don't know
could you create a demo of something
like a programming language that works
inside a web page uh it doesn't have to
be very good obviously it's just a demo
no one's actually going to use it just
do whatever you want basically
um do you think you can do it and
Brendan Ike took on the challenge and he
made oh is my sound gone strange
okay
uh am I back to normal yeah all right
good so Brenda Knight took on this
Challenge and he worked very hard for 10
days and he did create uh something that
could run inside a web browser and the
design directions that he was given at
the beginning there have influenced
JavaScript all the way up to the present
day for example Andreessen told him that
this can't be a compiled language
because he wanted people to be able to
just type the code straight into their
HTML files so it has to be just some
text that human beings type out and that
decision has stuck with us all the way
through the history of the web at least
up until we got up to webassembly that's
the first time we got away from that
particular design decision
and then CSS well
JavaScript was created sort of
unilaterally by one Corporation Netscape
but CSS was not CSS was a community
effort from the beginning all the
enthusiasts of the web at that time were
talking to each other over mailing lists
and so on and discussing how could we
create some sort of style sheet language
because you know we've seen this work in
the past even like Viola browser had
this what should it look like and there
was a bit of a design competition which
was ultimately won by this design by
hawk on William Lee and I know it
doesn't look much like CSS today it
doesn't have curly braces but it did set
much of the designs idea much of the
terminology was determined in this
original thing and hawkon went on to
work with someone else and they actually
you know made this what we know today
browsers were very slow to actually
adopt it but eventually they did
all right
let's talk about accessibility for a
minute that's a thing that we can't
afford to miss because if we do it's
going to burn us later all right so
accessibility has been a legal
requirement for web developers to think
about since the first incident that the
web was created because existing
legislation already talked about the
need to account for accessibility across
all products and services so as soon as
the web was invented it had to care
about this burners Lee knew about this
he wrote a message to the w3c newsletter
in 96 saying hey guys what about
accessibility like what should we do
what's what's the good practices what
technologies do we need to create to
make this work it started a conversation
which ended up with a meeting at the U.S
White House I heard involving some U.S
Congress person and during that they
founded the web accessibility initiative
and that gave the U.S legislature
confidence to make that part of their
updated section 508 great guidance that
came out the following year so that made
it very clear that the web was
absolutely subject to this accessibility
law and so to help developers make a
good job of that the web accessibility
initiative created these content
guidelines the web content accessibility
guidelines the following year they did
some updates and then many different
jurisdictions included that in their law
for example the EU in 2016 said well
basically you've got to do what the
version two of these guidelines said and
there was a further update a little bit
later the main thing I want you to take
away and understand from all this is a
little bit of a sense of gratitude that
this was done in the way it was because
imagine if these guidelines were not
created when they were what would have
happened instead is we'd have had 200
countries coming up with 200 different
sets of rules about what web
accessibility would be like and they
would all be written by people who
didn't even understand the web and you
would have to know about and comply with
all that but because these rules came
out early enough and they were written
by people who understand the web we've
got a fairly consistent set of rules to
follow globally and that's um something
we can actually do so that's nice
all right now let's get back into some
programming languages
so there was a bit of a problem
Microsoft was really getting into this
whole web thing around 2000 and of
course Microsoft had already got this
classic ASP thing but it was slightly
problematic people were writing very
messy code with their insecure code but
the worst problem was it was not object
oriented and in 2000 everything had to
be object oriented that was the law okay
and then second point was there was this
very successful technology called
Windows forms which had this beautiful
graphic designer why can't we have
something like that for the web so
someone you might have heard of Scott
Guthrie just started working at
Microsoft and his manager Mark Anders
was set the job of coming up with a
solution for this
so this is apparently the notebook they
used when they were designing the
original asp.net and I'm going to show
you what that looked like in the
beginning right now all right so it's
2000 2002 maybe you're a web developer
and you've just installed the uh the
Microsoft Visual studio.net the first
release of.net which also has got
asp.net in it so let's start that up oh
it's pretty fast right so that came up
kind of instantly
um I'm slightly cheating here by using
Hardware from 20 years in the future
obviously
um we still recommend that today if you
can for visual studio
um all right so I'm going to create a
new project right now all right and what
will I call it I don't really care what
it's called but when that's created
you'll see the first thing that comes up
is this visual designer we don't really
have those these days but let's see how
that goes right so I'm going to put some
stuff in there and
ah I've got to use the actual keys that
correspond to what I want to type there
we go right and then I'm going to use a
button as well and we can do some really
high-end graphic design as well so I'm
going to give that a nice sort of peach
background color that's cool
um let's see what kind of markup we're
actually creating here
surprisingly not that bad Okay so we've
got a form with a label and a button
that kind of makes sense there's some
bits about this that I don't know what
they are and I don't even know want to
know what they are like what is that I
don't know probably evil let's just
pretend we don't see it okay I'm going
to press Ctrl F5 now and it's going to
open up this thing in my browser all
right I can click the button nothing
happens because I didn't add any
Behavior but adding behavior is really
really nice so I double click on the
button and I can start typing out some
Behavior so I'm going to say that when I
do click on it I want the button one
text to change and it will become you
clicked at
uh date time dot now so I'm using the
brand new c-sharp programming language
there and when I click that the text on
the button does change each time I click
it all right now how does that work
because when we've got this kind of
stateful interactive Behavior even
though the web is stateless this is not
using JavaScript because at this time
JavaScript is just this ridiculous toy
language that you can't really do
anything with so how does it actually do
it well there is a way we can kind of
see what's going on if I use the back
button notice that I'm able to travel
backwards and forwards through time
that's pretty bizarre isn't it it's kind
of advanced we don't even do that with
modern web Tech so how is that working
well it's working like this
if I go and view the page source
it's generating this thing called view
State a hidden field which contains this
huge base64 blob that represents the
whole state of the UI and every time I
click that button it's sending that to
the server it decodes it to get the
state of the UI it runs my event handler
updates the UI re-serializes it all back
out as HTML and view State again so it's
a pretty clever solution to the problem
of statefulness on the web and it does
run into a few problems but you know
it's a pretty good thing at that time
and in fact a lot of people at that time
might think that this is it you know
we've reached the Pinnacle of web
programming it's object oriented there's
a designer it cannot get any better than
this but some people had different ideas
and one of the biggest things that
changed how people thought about web
development at that time was something
that landed a couple of years later
rails we're going to talk about Ruby on
Rails okay so David heinemeier Hansen
dhh he's a bit of a controversial figure
these days but at that time he was just
a poor humble hipster web developer who
decided that none of the existing
programming languages were good enough
for what he was doing so he had to go
out on this spiritual quest to find an
artisanal handcrafted scripting language
from Japan that no one else had heard
about in order to create his product and
he found Ruby which wasn't much known of
by anyone outside Japan at that time
and he built an application with it
called Basecamp which was pretty
commercially successful and from his
experience there he extracted a
framework and he published it as open
source and it made a really big impact
because it brought loads of new ideas
absolutely loads it was kind of amazing
really how much new stuff came in this
all at once so I'm going to show you all
right right here I've got rails version
1.0 which is not the very first ever
release of rails but it's the oldest one
that I could make work and I'm going to
use it to create a blog and we'll see
what the programming experience is like
first new thing here is notice I didn't
use an IDE or a wizard to create this I
just use the command line all right so
that was quite interesting now I'm going
to create I'm going to start this
running so I'm going to run the server
script that's also a little bit new I
didn't install a web server onto my
computer I just ran this script let's
see what it actually does shall we so
over here it says hey you're riding the
rails very exciting fighting we're
getting started and it gives us some
startup steps like start by defining
what your database is going to be in
this file okay so we'll do that I'll go
over to the database config and I'll say
I want it to use sqlite3 all right now
this is a yaml file which is yet another
new thing as far as web developers are
concerned at that time and again another
new thing I'm going to create some code
Now using a generator
so I'm going to use the command line to
generate myself a controller
called blog with an index action on it
all right so that's generated a bunch of
stuff and if we look over here we can
start to see the architecture of this
thing we've got models views and
controllers so it's MVC now dhh didn't
invent MVC but he was probably the main
person who popularized it for
server-side web programming and we can
uh see how this pattern influenced many
different phases of web development
later all right so we've got this
controller we've just created how are we
going to get to it in our web browser
well another new idea that was brought
in here was this convention over
configuration approach we don't have to
configure our router it just follows
conventions based on the names of our
files all right now let's make this do
something I'm going to need to have a
model so I'm going to generate a model
for a post in the blog all right and
it's generated not only that but also
some automated test code again yet
another thing that developers were not
expecting at that time and now I can
generate some UI for that so I'm going
to say I want to scaffold a UI for the
thing that's called post like that
all right so again another new thing
here because developers did not expect
the system to generate the UI for them
got a bit of a problem which is it's
trying to read from my database and I
don't yet have a table in my database
for these posts so we'll create one and
we'll do that using another New Concept
A migration
so migration a way of defining encode
changes to your database schema so I'll
create one for the posts table like that
and then that's going to generate this
file here and I can write in some logic
to control what's going to be in that
table I'll have a title and a body all
right so to run that I'm going to run
rake migrate like that that updates my
local database schema then I'll start up
the server one more time run that again
and we've got actual working UI now so I
can have this is
cool and it actually works and it saves
content in the database we've got an MVC
architecture we've got automated tests
we've got command line tools you can see
how incredibly different this
development experience was to what we
just did five minutes ago in visual
studio and web forms hugely hugely
different and very influential
and we'll see how it goes to onto
influence different aspects of
JavaScript in the future
so let's start thinking about JavaScript
a bit more now and front-end development
I think that JavaScript was kind of
reborn between the years of about 2005
and 2008. uh prior to that people
weren't really taking it seriously but
um as of about 2005 there were
commercial pressure that forced people
to take it seriously and that was mainly
to do with the Web 2.0 wave so Web 2.0
it's a funny name but basically that was
the time when companies realized that
they could extract a lot of commercial
value from user generated content so
loads of sites started springing up in
which it was all about user submitting
content and then communicating with each
other and if you're a user which sites
are you going to spend your precious
time creating content for well among
other things it's going to be the ones
that have got a nice UI that make it fun
friendly and quick to make some nice
content in there so there was a lot of
pressure to create the best uis and some
of the best work in this area was done
by Google and they brought out this
thing Google Maps which at the time was
absolutely mind-blowing I remember I was
a new web developer at this time and
when I saw Google Maps for the first
time the fact that you could drag this
map around you you could zoom in and out
and it wasn't reloading the page it was
just absolutely mind-blowing and
developers across the whole world just
absolutely lost their minds over this
because we did not know that you could
do that sort of thing and everyone
wanted to create user interfaces that
were as slick as that but no one really
knew how to do it
everyone was sort of coming up with
their own techniques but after a little
while one thing started to stick and it
was thanks to this blog post by Jessie
James Garrett who came up with this
terminology of Ajax asynchronous
JavaScript and XML and he said well
let's look at what Google's doing okay
let's start to extract some principles
about what their ux patterns are there
and more than that let's try and
understand some of the technology that
they're using behind it and he came up
with words with patterns and terminology
to describe this and some of it was
right and some of it wasn't quite right
you know some of it didn't stand the
test of time for example he talked a lot
about XML and he talked about this thing
called engines which is not a thing we
talk about these days but one
fundamental thing he did get right was
this idea of making requests in the
background to a server while the page
was there and updating the Dom
dynamically that obviously stuck with us
and that seems like a basic and obvious
thing today but it wasn't basically
obvious at the time and one other thing
that really helped that to catch on was
the arrival of this Library jQuery which
I'm sure most of you have heard of most
of you probably still use today and that
allows people to simplify the big mess
of Dom code to something much smaller
and it was very very successful it was
the first like Ultra Mega successful
JavaScript library at one point it was
used by nearly 70 of all websites and if
you look at where that Peak is on the
timeline it's only just started coming
down so it's amazingly successful
so think about it now you're a web
developer you're writing a lot of
JavaScript by now
um but how are you going to debug it
what's the state of browser Dev tools at
that time okay well let's have a look
shall we we'll go back into this browser
Internet Explorer 6 and we'll open the
browser Dev tools menu which is in here
no no it isn't in here because there are
no browser Dev tools at this time the
closest that you can get to Dev tools
right now is open the source in notepad
that's it you know that's what you've
got and you're gonna like it now not
everybody felt that way all right there
was one person called Joe Hewitt who had
previously been one of the engineers on
Firefox he left Mozilla and he went to
start his own thing he started creating
a browser sorry created web applications
and while he was creating web
applications he started to realize this
is a pain right there's no debugging
tools can I do something about that so
he and a small community created a
browser extension for Firefox called
Firebug let me show you what that looks
like
because you're going to recognize a lot
of this right this is an old version of
Firefox it's version two and inside it
I've got the Firebug extension installed
and that gives this inspector with a
console HTML view CSS it's got a script
debugger it's got Network Trace really
really familiar stuff pretty much the
same UI design that is used today in
browser Dev tools so this was very
popular it caught on very quickly a lot
of web developers started using it and
even it started to get copied and
integrated into Firefox itself it was
also fairly well copied by Google so
this was uh Chrome version 1.0 that came
out around that time very very old
version of Chrome but it still works
with the modern Google website and we
can go to inspect element in there and
you can see this is their first browser
Dev tools it doesn't really have as much
stuff in it as Firebug does but they
started to copy more and more of the
stuff over time
all right so now people could start to
write quite a lot of JavaScript and that
set the stage for JavaScript escaping
from the browser and getting onto the
server as well
node.js so Ryan dial he was a rails
developer and he was very influenced by
these Web 2.0 style user interfaces
where things would update all the time
in the background he loved that and he
wanted to do that but the problem was
his web server couldn't handle more than
one thing at a time he wanted to make
rails uh do multiple things at a time
and his first idea was to use
multi-threading but it didn't work
because rails wasn't multi-threaded Ruby
itself didn't handle that and nor did
python the other thing he tried but then
he had a brainwave JavaScript another
scripting language is not multi-thirded
either but it handles concurrency using
an event Loop and it just so happens at
the same time that Google open sourced
their VA JavaScript engine and so he
says that it was obvious to him that he
should create a web server based on V8
that used an event Loop for concurrency
now it doesn't seem obvious to me but he
thought it was obvious so he did he quit
his job he spent six months working on
this and then he released it at a
conference and it was obviously a huge
influence on the web to this day
okay but JavaScript was not finished yet
JavaScript is a monster that wants to
eat everything and it's not enough just
for people to write small web
applications or server-side applications
it needs big applications as well that
brings us into Spa Frameworks
JavaScript had another little rebirth
but when this book came out people
started to realize there was actually
quite a decent language hidden inside
JavaScript somewhere and people wanted
to use it to build bigger and bigger
applications
this slide here represents the
connections and The Inspirations between
different JavaScript Frameworks now I
did not create this slide I have stolen
it from Sarah drazner she's a director
of engineering at Google and she's one
of the most authoritative people in the
world on this subject because not only
does she run the team that has goo that
has angular in it she's also on The View
core team and was a peanut speaker at
react conf so really knows how this
stuff together goes together and I
absolutely can relate to and appreciate
all of these different arrows it makes
sense to me and I want to focus on this
first wave here that came out in 2010
because a load of people started doing
the same thing all at the same time the
time was right for it the first one of
these Frameworks to be public really
publicly released was backbone which did
a Hacker News Post on October 13th of
2010 and then exactly one week later
knockout that was my project that did a
Hacker News Post uh you know exactly
seven days later and it just so happened
turns that on the very same day
angularjs did its first public release
as well now angular red existed for a
while inside Google but it was Private
it only went public on that particular
day so there was no coordination among
these things it was just a time that the
world was ready for this and it had to
happen a bunch of people did it at the
same time
so I'm going to show you an example and
in honor of the fact that backbone got
the first release out I'm going to show
you a backbone application
so you can see how this would work so
the core thing here is Javascript
developers were exceeding the boundaries
of what could be done with jQuery the
applications were getting too messy with
just big bundles of event handlers but
people knew that it could be done better
because they'd seen rails for example
they knew that things like model view
controller architecture was possible so
could we do that for browser side code
as well and that's what backbone was all
about so here we've got this simple
example I didn't create this I'm just
going to show you the UI running so
let's get that open it's just a to-do
list you know we've all seen that sort
of thing before we can add stuff we can
mark it as done or not but the important
thing is how it's structured so we've
got a model we've got views and we've
got a controller-ish sort of thing now
MVC is a bit weird because everyone
knows what models and Views are but no
one really agrees what controllers are
it's just whatever is needed to make
models and Views work together
um that's really the core important
thing is this model view separation
that's the core of the pattern and the
way it's done inside backbone is like
this so we've got a model for our
to-do's and one for the to-do lists
we've got a way of calculating data
based on what's in the model you know
like how much stuff is done or remaining
and then to represent that as a UI
backbone uses the underscore templating
engine
now underscore is a JavaScript library
created by Jeremy ashkenas who was a
developer I think he was working at the
New York Times at the time and Ash can
ask created underscore he also created
backbone which we're looking at now and
then he went on to create coffeescript
which we will mention in a minute
because that was very influential too so
ashkenaz had a big impact on the web
around this time and the way that uh
backbone is rendering its views is like
this so it's got this render method and
you use it to call to create some HTML
from the model and then finally we've
got this controller that binds various
events inside the browser so that they
will update the model and in turn that
re-renders The View
so that's some basic MVC stuff in the
browser and like I said many different
people started doing this at the same
time it caught on very quickly all these
libraries were used at pretty high scale
and most of them stuck with us to this
day or at least newer versions of them
did and we'll talk about what that
ultimately evolves into in a few minutes
all right so during this time we are now
in a period of very very rapid expansion
of complexity people are not just
exceeding the boundaries of what jQuery
can do they're exceeding the boundaries
of what all these MVC Frameworks can do
as well our applications are becoming so
big we don't just need a new framework
we now need a new language to help
people to write code at a higher scale
and that's where typescript came along
typescript compiles to JavaScript as you
may well know it wasn't the first
language to do that coffeescript I don't
know if coffeescript was actually the
first but it was certainly the first one
that really caught on and got a lot of
people to understand that that was an
interesting way to create a language and
typescript followed on from that so
Anders heilsberg creator of C sharp and
various other people inside Microsoft
got together and said well thanks for
the inspiration ashken us how about we
use a similar technique but now we'll
use some Modern type Theory and
everything we know from c-sharp and so
on to create a really nice type system
for JavaScript and that was very very
successful that went from zero users 10
years ago to you know being something
like the second most popular programming
language in the world today so
incredible growth of popularity really
required and the fact that we now need
to compile gives rise to other parts of
the tool chain for example webpack is a
build and bundling system which is
needed because people are now you know
compiling from typescript they're
processing SAS and less and bundling all
kinds of stuff like you know it's
complicated right you're dealing with
this sort of stuff all the time webpack
was there for that and I've thrown in
kubernetes as well mainly just to try
and completely mentally exhaust you
because I want you to appreciate that
like seriously this is so much stuff
going on right now as a web developer
you don't just need to know a
client-side self server-side stuff
special languages build systems all that
you've got to understand Cloud
orchestration as well and like sure
isn't it enough like don't I do enough
and yes it's a lot okay maybe it's
exceeding the limits of what individual
developers can be expected to understand
and maybe some sort of pushback might
need to start happening and we'll talk
about that in a minute all right one
last thing before we get to that though
another technology came on the scene a
couple of years later which has had a
big impact it's important to me at least
uh webassembly uh this was the first
place where we got away from
andreessen's design direction to say you
just have to be able to type out the
code okay so this is uh what we say if
if we imagine we can compile from any
language any platform to some kind of
bytecode that we're running in a browser
well that's what webassembly is all
about uh that was a joint project from
Mozilla Google Microsoft and some webkit
developers at Apple and that has enabled
various new kinds of Technologies to get
into a browser now do you know what the
absolute best thing is that you can do
with webassembly well I've got an
opinion about that and I'm going to show
you an example of it right now which is
running.net inside a browser so for just
as an example of webassembly for no
other reason or agenda at all I'm going
to give you uh the original Blazer
Prototype all right so Blazer is a way
of running.net or it was at that time a
way of running.net code inside a browser
it's coming a long way since then and
this was the original prototype uh if
you've used any Blazer you might
recognize this particular project
template because embarrassingly we still
haven't changed it after all these years
and I keep saying every year can we
please change it now and we haven't done
yet but the important thing is that it's
um oh I better get back to the home page
and reload right so it's getting
some.net dlls here regular.net
assemblies that have been compiled with
the normal c-sharp compiler and running
them in the browser thanks to
webassembly we've got this runtime
dna.wasm dna.net anywhere that's not the
regular.net runtime it's a very
small.net runtime created by one person
called Chris bacon and that compiles
very easy to easily to webassembly to
produce this tiny 22 kilobyte file that
can run.net code inside the browser so
that was enabled by the fact that this
webassembly tooling came along and many
other things I've been enabled too just
a couple of days ago flutter announced
that they were going to get Dart running
inside of browser on webassembly as well
so we see more and more movement in that
direction
okay right we're running low on time so
what about this decade that we're in now
I'm not going to talk too much about
stuff that's happened over the last
couple of years because the dust hasn't
really settled yet we don't know what's
going to turn out to be important and
what isn't but I do want to pick out a
few trends that I think are interesting
and might set a bit of direction for
where things are going one of them is
that yes things are too complicated
we're asking developers to deal with so
many different things could we simplify
that a little bit by bringing some of
the complexity as native features in the
browser
so we've got some uh proposals and specs
that change things a little bit for
example HTTP two and three they mean
that it's now just as efficient to send
lots of small files to the browser as it
is to bundle and send one big file so
that simplifies a bit of the build
process potentially the type Erasure
proposal that would allow browsers to
run languages like typescript without
needing to be compiled first just by
teaching them to ignore the parts of the
syntax that they don't understand and
then finally CSS nesting that allows you
to get much of the benefits that you do
with things like lesson SAS but without
having to pre-process it so you can just
Nest all your selectors together and get
a better syntax and it just so happens
that last week the chromium project
announced that they were definitely
going ahead with CSS nesting so that's
nice to see another way in which things
might get simplified a little bit is
with more of JavaScript taking over
things or with this time with single
page application Frameworks taking over
not just what happens inside the browser
but the server as well and integrating
that stuff together so you don't have to
deal with two different programming
Styles and you don't necessarily have to
deal with as much build stuff because
they integrate it all together and I'm
going to show you an example of that in
a second and finally I just wanted to
mention it's a little bit separate but
one of the complexities we deal with is
thinking about where we deploy our sites
and whether the servers are up or down
and so on one way we could mitigate that
is if instead of deploying to just a few
locations we deployed to thousands or
tens or hundreds of thousands of the
locations at the cloud Edge and that way
we don't really have to make decisions
about where stuff gets deployed all the
users get very low latency and you
pretty much can't be down unless the
whole global internet is down so that's
one of the things that might help us a
little bit but let's get back to this
thing with Spa and meta Frameworks so
next asterisk felt cat solidstar and
others these are meta Frameworks uh
JavaScript developers are dealing with
so many Frameworks now you need a
framework to manage your Frameworks and
that's what a meta framework kind of is
but it's also about having something
that spans server client build and
deployment
gonna give you an example now svalket
because it's got a bunch of new and fun
ideas in it okay so I've created this
project here using this Felker template
and doesn't really have anything in it
just yet it's just this sort of hello
page okay and let's have a look at some
of the code in here well we've got a
page.svelt file which has just got some
markup in it and of course it's got some
basic features that we all expect today
like hot reload so if I press save you
know it's going to update in the browser
that's to be expected but slightly more
usefully it also bundles things like
Styles as well so we don't have to worry
about how styles are actually deployed
or how they get into the browser we just
add some style wherever we feel like it
and it's going to appear suitably in the
browser so that simplifies stuff a
little bit
show you more interesting features I'll
have to add a bit more functionality so
I'm going to create a counter everyone
loves counter examples it's sort of the
hello world of Spar programming so I'm
going to create a new page that's got
the very special magic name of page.s
felt with a plus sign and that is part
of svelt's approach to convention over
configuration they've got this
convention which is that if you call a
file this then it's just going to show
up so it's kind of using some of the
ideas from rails there and you can see
it's also got built-in support for
typescript so this is fully typed data
and I've got my initial count I'm
displaying it I've got a button when you
click it it's going to update that count
all right so if I come back over here
and if I want to get to that I just
follow the convention like I said and I
end up on the right place and then I can
click this button and it works all right
nothing particularly special or
impressive just yet but let's start
thinking about how we can spam server
and client and to do that I'm going to
factor out a little bit of the logic
here I want to factor out the logic that
decides what the data is and any other
data loading logic so I'm going to
create a new file here called page Dot
TS and you can think of that as being a
kind of code behind file so it's sort of
taking a bit of inspiration from web
forms I suppose you could say that and
inside there I'm going to add some
content here I'm going to Define the
initial count now as being one two three
and don't really need that line so let's
get rid of that okay and now I've got a
load function which is exported and
that's going to return it so I'm not
doing anything really different here
other than just factoring some stuff out
I just want to use that factored out
code here inside my UI all right so it's
still all running inside the browser but
now the initial count is one two three
instead of zero and it goes up from
there
but this change that I make is getting
lost every time I re-load the page it's
lost and every user has got their own
separate count could we create a
globally shared count by having the
count State live on the server instead
without having to change too much code
well yes we can one very interesting
thing that we can do with a meta
framework like this is I can simply
rename this file to page.serverts and
just by making that file name change
with that file will now execute server
side rather than client-side so whenever
the user navigates to this page it's it
will actually make it an HTTP call to
the server to get the result back from
this load function so now we can control
the data loading on the server that's
good but you'll notice that when I
reload it still loses the changes that's
because when we mutate the state we're
just mutating it inside the browser's
memory let's say that we want to mutate
it on the server instead so we want to
expose an API endpoint that we can call
we can do it really easily by simply
exporting something called actions and
now we've got an endpoint that we can
call from the browser to increment that
account all right so to actually call
that on the server I don't want a button
that just mutates stump in browser
memory I'm going to use an HTML form
that will that will post to the
increment action on the server okay I
know I'm doing a lot of stuff very
quickly but hopefully you can get the
idea that we've got a form you post it
to this endpoint on the server it
mutates the count and then the load
state will go back down to the browser
okay so now when I click this you'll see
when I reload I don't lose my changes
and in fact if there are other users in
other browsers they would also be
sharing the same account
how is this actually working though on
The Wire well if we look at it you'll
see every time I click this if you look
at the browser Dev tools it's fully
reloading the entire page so we're doing
a post to the server and regenerating
the page on the server which means we've
kind of reinvented web forms again now
so that's all coming back and that's
kind of useful if you want to support
users who don't have JavaScript enabled
excuse me but this user does
of JavaScript enabled so could we make
things even better for them well yes we
can
I can go to this form here and I can put
this magic tag on it saying use enhance
okay and when I've done that what it's
going to do is uh that's not the one I
want what I want is come on tooling you
can wake up no controlling won't wake up
there we go right so what that's going
to do now is that if the browser has
JavaScript enabled it won't do a full
page load anymore it's not refreshing
the page it's just sending a message to
the server to say hey I want to call
this endpoint tell me what how the UI
should update and then it's doing
client-side rendering from there on so
now we've mixed server side logic and
client-side logic and we're doing either
server-side rendering or client-side
rendering depending on what this
particular client supports and in terms
of all the build and bundling stuff
that's all baked in there as well so in
many ways this sort of meta framework
can simplify things and reduce some of
the things that developers have to deal
with if you're wondering what that means
if you're a net developer well we've got
similar stuff in the pipeline in.net a
as well
okay so that is the end of what we've
had time for uh the web has come on a
long way since burners Lee's original
proposal I'm not sure if he quite
understood what he was unleashinged on
the world when he wrote this document uh
the thought I want to leave you with as
you go out into the rest of the
conference is think about how the
decisions were made and who made the
decisions along the way in a few cases
it was major corporations who made
decisions but in a lot of cases it was
actually individual Engineers so think
about Nicola pelo deciding to create a
linemer browser think about Joe Hewitt
who decided that existing browser Dev
tooling was good enough or think about
Ryan Dahl who came up with this idea of
having a javascript-based event Loop web
server just individual Engineers who had
a bit of inspiration have made it happen
and right now you are those Engineers
you're at this conference you're talking
to each other you're sharing your ideas
and you are hopefully going to come up
with some of the next wave in web
technology so I'm very excited to see
what you come up with and hopefully be
part of it so go and enjoy the rest of
the day and the rest of the conference
and um yeah that's all from me thank you
very much
[Applause]